على مدى اربع بطولات من المونديال وخلال
اثني عشر عاما دخلت الحيوانات في اطار
التسليه والحماسه الموندياليه عبر
استخدامها بتوقع نتائج مباريات اصابت هذه
الحيوانات في مرات واخطات في اخرى الباندا
الحالي هو الاقل دقه على ما يبدو لكن في
هذا المونديال تحديدا يدخل الذكاء
الاصطناعي بقوه في التوقعات مع استمرار
مباريات المونديال الحالي يتوقع كمبيوتر
عملاق هويه الفائز في نهائيات كاس العالم
الكمبيوتر توقعات فوز فرنسا بالمونديال
الحالي لكن بنسبه تقارب ال18%
[موسيقى]
اليوم كمبيوتر خارق ضرب توقعات كل
الحيوانات يعني يمزج بين التوقعات
والتحليلات الرقميه يخرج بنتائج مباريات
المونديال من الناحيه التقنيه كيف يمكن
تفسير ذلك
الحيوانات
اللي موجوده موجوده من مباريات سابقه تشمل
نفس الفريقين وموجوده ايضا من المباريات
سابقه للفريقين مع منتخبات اخرى فبالتالي
قدرات والقوه اللي موجوده مع كل لاعب
واللي تم رصدها من خلال الحساسات
المستشفيرات والاداء المباريات الماضيه
تلعب دور جدا مهم فالايام تدخل فيها
خوارزميات الجو تدخل فيها ايضا خالص يعني
ملعب
محلي كلها تدخل فيها فبال الفرص حقت نقدر
نقول التوقعات يظل مبنيه على بيانات وليست
مبنيه على نقدر نقول فقط حركات طيب فيصل
هناك ظروف دائما غير متوقعه في الساحره
الخضراء المستطيله يعني ارهاق اجهاد نفسي
ضغوط نفسيه وحتى اصابات غير متوقعه تكون
حتى لكبار اللاعبين والمحترفين في هذه
الحاله الا اما توقعات الكمبيوتر خارق
تكون نسبيه
ذكر الكمبيوتر تتوقعات وارتفعت هذه النسبه
هي ظل كون الامر مرتبط بالبشر فيه عامل
البشر العامل البشري هو النقطه الاكبر في
احداث اي تغيير وفي عامل اكثر من كده اكيد
سبحان رب العالمين
ايش اللي يصير نتيجه وبالتالي لو رجعنا
على امر نستخدم فيه التوقعات لعشرات السنه
الثانيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مع قواعد بيانات تمتد احيانا الى 100 سنه
ما بين المنتخب الاسباني والمنتخب المغربي
على سبيل المثال عشرات المرات كانت تواجد
جدا بالتالي نسبه حدود التوقعات ايضا
[تصفيق]